if somebody is in their head convinced
that you take steroids
it's almost impossible to change their
mind the thing that annoys me is when
people will message me like i just think
you're such a role model
but now that i know that you're not
natural i just
because of some guys we do on youtube
there's a lot of people who are taking
gear and they don't
look that great now let's say for
example i'm one of those people i'm
taking a lot of gear and i look okay and
then i see a physique like mine and i'd
be like god
if this is what i look like and i'm
taking all this imagine what he's taking
they cannot comprehend that i'm actually
not taking anything
at all
ladies and gentlemen welcome back i'm
joined by
the one and only mike t's in the
building michael
thurston how are you i'm good living
life in dubai right now
can't complain so good to see the last
time that we saw each other when
was that is that
we keep on bumping in into each other in
[ __ ] boy cities don't somewhere
yeah it was a it was a brief meeting up
but obviously abby was very different
this year so how long are you out there
for
from july until mid-october
it was it was definitely an interesting
year but in a way it was a good thing
because there was less temptation
i get to to explore the island and train
keep on track with my eating sleeping so
it was it was a nice little break from
dubai yeah now you're back here six
months
yes until may at least the plan is
dubai is going to be on base for the
next few years because i do like it it's
got everything i need
very suitable for what i want my
lifestyle
the only problem i had with it is the
summer is absolutely brutal like it is
so
unbearable yeah and i'm type president
like to be outside i like to sit outside
outside walk and you just can't really
do that when it gets too hot
so from definitely june until
august it's not the best place to be so
i kind of dip out and we'll most likely
return back to europe
got any ideas where you're going to be
next year i'll explain a lot
but i'm going to plan closer
to the summer because last year or this
year should i say i planned everything
way too far in advance
and obviously all this madness happened
and
[Music]
it was just chaos i basically paid for
my accommodation in ibiza
upfront expecting to have the best swim
of my life as i turned 30 years old
and i'm like oh my god what the hell am
i supposed to do now because i don't
even know if i'll be able to get into
spain
because they closed the borders until
july but because i paid for my
accommodation in
spain for that apartment i was like well
i'm going to make it work make the most
out of it yeah i feel like i did what i
could with
you know the situation um we had
it was it was a good summer but not
quite different than someone that i
expected
yeah we've known each other i'm trying
to work out how long we've known each
other i think it's like 12 years because
we're at uni together
yeah but we must have bumped into each
other my first year of uni when i was in
the uni gym yeah when i was 18.
18 years old a much smaller version
very small than iqt yeah exactly yeah
and
when did you pivot from being in the uk
there was a period you were
owning a gym going to gym in the uk did
a bunch of other stuff and then when
did that pivot happen the change yeah
i think that was when when i left
newcastle i moved to london
because there was something about london
which i feel was calling my name every
time i went to london i got a buzz
i've been there um and then
when i made that transition from
training people in person
personal training uh to online coaching
and starting my youtube channel i was
then free to do my job
anywhere in the world as long as i had
laptop camera
and obviously a gym so that's when i
started
doing a lot of traveling 2018 2019 i
probably did the most traveling
um and then this year obviously not a
huge amount of traveling but just
living in a different country i've been
in the uk since 2019.
so what's a typical day look like for
you
everybody that watches your vlogs will
know that there's sometimes you're in a
lamborghini driving through the desert
or you skydiving or training
with larry wheels or doing whatever but
what's a typical day or a typical week
walk us through every i'd say every day
is different
i think one of the things which i like
most about my life now is i can wake up
and i can decide what the hell i want to
do with that day so if i'm like right i
want to make a video i want to do a
collab or want to do something new and
exciting
i'll go off and i'll do it but if
the opposite is true and i'm like well
you know what i just want to chill today
and just
go to the pool go to the beach relax
listen to a podcast or
audiobook take it easy then that's what
i'll do so
what i do on a day-to-day basis is
dependent upon my mood
and what my schedule looks like youtube
wise
i guess youtube is sort of dictating
what i'm doing with my life at the
moment
and what i'm trying to do is two videos
a week sometimes i don't always stick to
that schedule
um it just i don't want to put i don't
want to rush something and put something
else mediocre i'd rather spend a bit
more time
on it and then put out a good video um
[Music]
but yeah every day is different
how do you keep yourself disciplined
because i'm come out to dubai and my
schedules like all
over the place i don't know what time
i'm supposed to be getting up all of the
structures
and the routines that i usually rely on
to make sure that i'm continuing to
progress in different areas of my life
in the gym in
reading and meditation in recording
everything
the difficulty level has been increased
how do you ensure that you don't just
get
totally blown away by a party lifestyle
or a distraction lifestyle or a
sightseeing
new experience how are you keeping
yourself disciplined
i think the hardest thing i've found now
is as my sort of followings grow
you get more people reaching out to you
more people are wanting to meet with you
particularly in places like ibiza and
dubai there's a very
active social scene and you know
party scene um and one of the biggest
things which
has been a game changer for me is just a
lot of times not drinking
drinking is a recipe for just ruining
everything my productivity
my my gym workouts my sleep
everything so if i do go to any of these
events or whatever i'll most likely
not drink most of the time that's helped
massively
um i've also found that
usually what i'll do in the morning is
i'll write a list
of things which definitely 100 need to
get done on that day
you got any idea of what that was today
or recently can you think of a list that
you bring
uh yes so i'm trying to think of
yesterday
yesterday was to film a workout with a
guy called
brandon harding and then after that was
to do a little bit of video editing
then to shoot some content for my
protein because
black friday's coming up and i do some
promote for them
and then there's some
boring admin stuff like emails and
things like that what i try and do is
not make the list too long because
i'm so good at making lists and i'm
quite terrible at taking things off so
uh yeah i just i just think i could just
do three or four things
just make sure that they're done try and
get the hardest thing done first
i try i find that i'm like way more
productive in the morning when i wake up
i can what's your typical wake-up time i
know it might change based on whether
you've been out
or not but so when do you aim to get up
for luckily for me i can wake up when i
want and i don't have an alarm like i
wake up when my body wants to wake up
and the goal is to try and get seven to
eight hours sleep
and the thing which i've noticed about
dubai because the sun sets quite early
the days are short
so i because there's a lot stuff going
on a night
i don't want to be staying up too late
because that means that i wake up later
and then there's less of the day to take
advantage of so
i am trying to wake up at nine o'clock
it's not going very well
you messaged me last night at half four
in the morning asking if we could push
this back by four hours
yeah so this is the crazy thing about
dubai because we were
it was me louie and then this other guy
were like oh gonna find some
somewhere to eat and there was this one
place which i've never tried before
it's called london project which is just
a walk away from mine
and i'd met someone in the gym who's
invited me to go there because she knows
the owner i was like okay cool so i
dropped my message said oh by the way
i'm going here
uh you know kind of hoping that she
would message them
the owner turned out to be there he
introduced himself and then he gave us
this like unbelievable
service food drinks like coming out with
cocktails even though i didn't want to
drink
i maybe had a few but my friend louie he
had quite a lot
and then it was like amazing and that's
when the night should have stopped
but the owner then came with like one of
his co-workers and he'd had
quite a few drinks he was like come come
and sit with us
i was just like no like what time is
this
this
is probably about 12 30. going on time
yeah so obviously i don't want to be
ruining that okay well
i'll sit down and anyway we all sit down
there's probably about
eight of us just chatting away and it
turns out he's this
massive big time guy from australia who
is the son
of probably one of the wealthiest family
wealthiest families in
australia so we had this like
unbelievable chat
about so many different things he's like
doing lots of things he wants to get me
involved
get louie involved and then the night
just carried on until about
3 30 in the morning and i kept saying to
him i was like look i've got a podcast
the next day like
i need to go and he was like five more
minutes
[Laughter]
and i was just like this is just typical
dubai like all i wanted to do was just
go out
for a nice meal and then you end up
going to this place
getting looked after and then meeting
someone who is
somewhere else to a lot of people that
sounds like a dream world right
but i imagine that when that becomes
consistent
you must get do you ever get sort of
anxiety or a level of frustration
that you can't knuckle down and do
things quite as easy i was i was
frustrated last night so i was like i
i want to go to bed like because i have
stuff doing tomorrow and i know that
if i don't go asleep or if you know
i drink i'm i'm nowhere near as
productive the next day
and i i don't feel like i've wasted the
day but i feel like i could have done a
hell of a lot more in that day
and if you compound that over a couple
of weeks a couple of months before you
know it that becomes your life yeah
and the the thing with that is
especially with what i'm doing my
physique is almost my business
the way i look i take a lot of pride in
the way i look and i put a lot of work
and effort into
you know sculpting my physique and
looking a certain way and doing things
like that
going to bed late and drinking alcohol
is absolutely terrible
yeah like drinking if you drink like
more than three drinks it can
massively drop your testosterone levels
it takes like three days for them to go
back to normal
sleep as well so many disadvantages of
not getting
enough sleep um and i am aware of them
so makes it even worse yeah i'm just
like oh yeah here we go
how sick are you of people asking if
you're natural
god now at this point i'm used to it
because
i've been getting it for like a decade
like but what i've noticed is
a lot of it is really dependent upon the
type of content which i put out so when
i'm doing vlogs
and day-to-day stuff not many people
talk about steroids or anything like
that because the focus is
on something else like just happening
video when it peaked
uh recently was when i did uh a full
week of training in ibiza
my current split um and i was at the gym
training topless i'd managed to get
myself probably one of the best
conditions i've been in for a while
it's not that i was bigger it was just
that i was leaner so obviously when you
get leaner you have the
appearance of looking bigger but because
when i was in the gym
i was topless i was like seriously
pumped up
because my physique trains it changes a
lot from
you know me flattered but pumped up so i
was just like jesus like that looks
pretty damn crazy and then the whole
argument comes
with obviously naturals and not natural
and then
a few other big youtubers started making
videos on whether i'm natural
or not derek from more play tomorrow
yeah greg doucette
i think gregory said like three videos
of me this summer which is easy views
man
yeah so in a way it's good because i get
some publicity from him
but you know if someone thinks i've
taken something
most of the time they're always going to
think that there's not really much i can
do to change their mind
but the thing that annoys me is when
people message me like oh do you know
you actually think you're such a role
model but now that i know that you're
not natural
i just because of some guys on youtube
because he has a proper cult following
people believe everything he says and
what was this justification for why
you're on gear
because of the supposed low levels of
body fat which i have he said
body fat which is not true no way do i
have six percent why i would say most of
the time hovering around 10 11
but it's the distribution of where i
hold my body fat i don't have
a huge amount unlike my abs or like my
torso area it's like a lot of is on the
thighs
and lower back but
he definitely eyed that up wrong and i
think a lot of people
assume that i hold you know that peak
condition which i was in
they assume i'm like that all the time
but i'm not you know if i
times when i'm not looking my best i
just don't show it i don't like
when i'm looking like a little bit
chubbier for me i'm not going to take a
picture with myself like that
i'm going to find like the light and
where i look the best and then i'll show
people
that's what people need to understand
like when they see me in
especially instagram if you see pictures
of me topless
that is me when i'm looking my best
friend
if i've been to the gym got a pump on or
i've found like the right lighting
you know i'm picking the best picture of
like 20
to 30 with a pro photographer yeah
somebody who knows what angle to get
so there was that um
and does it irritate you does it does it
get to you it does when people say
that i'm a liar and the thing is i've
never made a video addressing this
because i there is no universal test to
prove that
someone is natural it doesn't exist
you there's things you can do to take
like a
the lie detector test you get blood work
done
there's a few other things you can do as
well but it doesn't prove
that you have never ever taken steroids
you know if i'd done all those things
you know and
people like okay well maybe you're
natural now but maybe a year ago or for
the you know from the age of 22 to 26
you would probably take steroids
to build a foundation and now you're not
so
it's annoying i wish that universal test
did exist so you could take it so you
can take it just take it if it would
take 100
and i would want everyone to take it
because it would be nice to know
[Music]
who actually is natural and who's not
imagine how much larry wheels would
break that test
i know there's a lot of people that
break that test
i do think there are some athletes out
there who are natural and they look
unbelievable
um there is also a whole lot of people
who
are taking stuff in the fitness industry
it's a very competitive industry and
people are trying to look the very best
people are willing to take or do
whatever it takes do you understand why
people
think that given the sort of condition
that you're in yeah
i think if i was looking at myself
i would definitely think um it's
achievable to get i don't think i'm like
freaky
i think everything's like in proportion
i don't have like crazy delts i don't
have like spots or anything
but this is the thing which is
interesting because i have friends a lot
of friends who have taken stuff
uh you know the guy was used to be in
business with
he was taking quite quite a lot of stuff
and he didn't look very good
like didn't look that impressive there's
a lot of people who are taking gear and
they don't
look that great now let's say for
example i'm one of those people i'm
taking a lot of gear
and i look okay and then i see a
physique like mine
and i'd be like god if this is what i
look like and i'm taking all this
imagine what he's taking they cannot
comprehend
that i'm actually not taking anything at
all
so that's something which i imagine if
anyone who's taking steroids
and they look at my physique and they
don't look anywhere near as good then
they will naturally just assume that i'm
taking something
and that will trigger them yeah um
[Music]
and what i i always like to show i'll
send you this picture you may put on
the individual make it make it appear
now there's a picture of me 10 years old
and like i have a very strange
development of like
i've got abs i've got like my calves
i've got biceps
and i'm like look this is me at 10 years
old before pmt
yeah so obviously i'm not a normal
person
like genetics are definitely in my favor
and because this is like my
biggest passions it's my career i've
dedicated my life to it
for the past decade i've been training
for 12 years
then yeah i'm gonna look quite good
one of the things i always find funny
about it is that because we've known
each other for so long
and i still know you as the guy that we
used to spot me in the gym and we used
to train together and do whatever at the
university gym
when training upstairs at the seat
center for sport and excellence in
newcastle uni
um and seeing that trajectory you've got
sort of linearly bigger
pretty much since i've known you so
maybe plateaued a little bit over the
last
like sort of four years conditions maybe
improved a little bit
we essentially just got linearly bigger
yeah from when we've known each other
yeah and i appreciate why people on the
internet
who look and see the end result think
that that's ridiculous but
i put up on my ig dean make it appear
now
uh yesterday of us when we were working
for
globe girls doing like hosting heavily
oiled up
very very oiled up yeah very slippery uh
like that and that's just this
sort of slow and steady way progression
another thing as well
i've been mates with your ex flatmates
your ex-girlfriends um and also them
watched your um progression i guess into
youtube
none of that you would have to have such
an unbelievable conspiracy network to
keep everybody quiet
yeah about what it is that you're on
yeah for no one amongst that
even like an ex-girlfriend is the
patient zero
for the person who would want to call
out the thing that would rumble
their ex and she never did right and
then
the only other thing like if anyone's
got questions and this is what i always
say because people know that i know you
and they say i'm [ __ ] now what's he
on
i'm like he travels to a lot of
different countries
how effective at smuggling dru like not
only is he a youtuber but he's also like
a top level drug runner
like smuggled testosterone and growth
hormone and insulin especially last year
the amount of places i went to last year
like effectively trying to do that would
have been
[Laughter]
so yeah i think when did it get worse
or when was there a period before you're
now quite equanimous and relaxed about
it
was there a period where you think i'm
gonna have to address this
when i started youtube that's when a lot
of the rumors came about
um and i wanted i wanted to address it i
wanted to put a video together but i
i was thinking so many times i thought
how to do this properly
it must be because because i've seen
other people do it and they failed
miserably
i've seen simian panda he tried to make
a video claiming that he was natural
and he got so much hate for it so much
hate what did he do wrong
i think people just don't believe him
they look at his physique and they're
like no
it's not possible that you're natural do
you think he is he could be
i don't know this is the thing i don't
know what all these people are doing
you just assuming and
all these people that make videos about
me it's like you don't know me you don't
know what i do
this is just you make an assumption
based on the way i look
it's what everyone is doing with simi
panda like
he does look he looks crazy he looks
freaky
but he could he could be genetic free
you know billions of people on this
planet there are going to be some
genetic freaks out there
and it's been a while since i've seen
that video but he did a lie detector
test i think he did a few other things
as well
people just straight up refused to
believe it like and if i was to do the
same thing
try and make this video do all these
tests if somebody
is in their head convinced that you take
steroids
it's almost impossible to change their
mind that would be an interesting one so
if there's people watching who think
that that would be a good idea for a
video
i'd love to know in the comments what
level of evidence they would accept
yeah to believe like if you were to do a
thing
an independently administered this test
or whatever
because i think you're quite right it's
kind of like
the boy that cried wolf happy to
continue to accuse you
of using pens but also
there is no level of evidence that they
would be happy with to accept it you're
not
yeah and even let's say for example
i was trying to imagine a world where
there actually was a test
then i would imagine people would pay
could possibly pay huge amounts of money
to cheat the test because that would
have a huge impact on their career
and then maybe how many programs they
sell so
i i just i can never i honestly wish
they'd never been invented i wish there
was didn't
exist because you wouldn't have because
that would be like up here
and then everyone else would be and
there wouldn't be all this [ __ ] and all
this like
pointless debates i used to to argue
with people i used to get into arguments
with people online
and try and prove you know the comments
like no no i'm not sure because i
learned it
just a huge waste of energy i spent all
day every day arguing with people as to
whether i'm breathing
on youtube yeah on youtube on instagram
whatever it might be and i'm like
it's not productive whatsoever can't
change your mind
time have you ever intended to take
steroids
um i've been curious to know what i
would look like but i think i would just
look
freaky like too big i don't want to be
that big like i'm actually
i've been very content with the way i
have looked and my progression
and i think now like you know it's kind
of plateaued i've kind of looked the
same for the past
few years if i wanted to take my
condition to the next level
what would have to happen is i'd have to
live a very
monk life existence the social life
would take a hit
everything would need to be very
regimented i probably need to have a
coach every session would need to be so
unbelievably
brutal my nutrition would have to be on
point every meal prepped no alcohol
no parties eight hours sleep every
single night
and yeah that would look better i
probably put on a bit size
but that's not a life i won't live it's
a price you're not prepared to pay yeah
i compete twice before
and did you yeah 2014 2015 wbff
okay and it was a good experience to
to actually go on stage and to go
through the whole process of competing
i didn't like it was the first time in
my life where i was like really not
happy with my physique
because i was just like oh god like i'm
just not leaning enough even though i
was [ __ ] shredded i was like
oh you can't see like the striations in
my ass
like who the hell cares about that but
that was like
the weird mindset that i was getting
into
are you concerned about having a
physique like yours and putting it out
online
about what sort of body dysmorphia that
might cause downstream
for me for other people are for other
people
uh yeah
because i think there's a lot of people
who would want to look
like me and it's
i don't want to be like brutal but i
want to be realistic with people
i think anyone should go out there with
a mindset of trying to achieve
their dreams and not letting anything
stop them
but if someone is like you know
they've got like kids they're working
like a really
stressful job and they have at the end
of the day
really [ __ ] genetics like they're gonna
have a very very hard time
coming close to looking like me when my
whole life is dedicated to looking like
this and i've got good genetics as well
so it's tough and that's why i've never
ever seen my videos you can look like me
i've never said that once
most of my videos have been put out
there to just
help people to stop making mistakes
which i've made like to
to just help them eat better eat the
right things and
to just more importantly just lift good
proper technique
technique is massive form execution
intensity most people lack that when
they go to the gym
so if everyone's focused on that a
little bit more they would be
a hell of a lot closer to looking the
way they want to look or the best that
they could possibly look
i think that's a good insight that when
people do the comparison game
we're not all starting from the same
base point yeah like
i i'm as much of a like [ __ ] talker and
a critic
as will be but i believe that you're
natural
and given that fact and given the way
that we've
both seen friends of ours mutual
acquaintances
jump on huge cycles and then come off
and not make
that much difference to their physique
you have to think like
there's something in you i know that
your passion is lifting weights
there's something in your particular
physiology
composition that doesn't actually want
you to be that big or that lame
yeah and the fact that that's that can
be true
means that sadly some people's passions
aren't actually what they're going to be
good at
you can love lifting weights but if your
love of lifting weights is determined by
the outcome
ie and goal physique that you get at the
end of it some people
are putting themselves into a situation
where the only outcome
is disappointment yeah things like that
should to feel the smaller
yeah it's funny because a lot of people
say oh you should do what you're really
passionate about
but sometimes you should just do what
you're really good at at the end of the
day
like uh when i
got into personal training i never
thought that i would be
like a good teacher but it turns out
that after
years of training people you have
thousands of hours with clients
i got quite good at breaking down quite
complex
terms or movements just making it easy
for people to understand
and that's what helped grow my channel
in the first place doing
tutorial videos and execution videos and
people are like oh my god like
it makes so much sense now i don't need
to use technical terms
to try and convey a point just talk
about it in simple terms for the
basic person to understand and then
we're like oh
[ __ ] that works so let's get on to that
because
after all of this time traveling
suboptimal environment
now it doesn't matter how good the gym
in dubai is it can't compensate for a 4
30 a.m finish
yeah and you're distracted with
offers for collaborations with different
people a lot of which won't involve
eating rice and broccoli and being in
the gym
so take us through like the principles
that you
use for training now so
i think the most important thing for me
is to just get the session
done going to the gym and having a good
session is the most important thing
the nutrition side of things if you're
eating
you know restaurants or cafes or you're
on the move
it's not going to be optimal and that's
you know that's just the way it is i
will try
to get my protein in you know
around 2 2 10 20 grams of protein a day
and what do you weigh
90's 95 kilograms of tomorrow so that's
about around about two yeah 2.2 over 2
grams per kilogram body weight
so if i get good session and get my
protein in yeah the my overall calorie
intake for the day
i won't know it exactly but if i can hit
roughly the
the right figure then i'll be okay i can
maintain
um so we've got compliance aim to hit
your protein
it's the consistency of going to the gym
that's what most people suck at because
they go
weeks or months with not going or they
have shitty sessions so does that
get the protein in the oval overall
calorie intake in
i don't like the fats in the carb ratio
that can
vary it doesn't matter huge amount way
way too many people get stressed out
about that
protein overall carrying takes the most
important things in my opinion
um and then get a good night's sleep a
lot of people underestimate
the power of sleep and if i can do that
i can continue to look
good also i would also say
the the quality of the food has a big
factor
on the way you look and feel and perform
and one thing which
i would say is not good for me is eating
highly processed foods and the sugar
what the place did you fall off with
that uh
what do you mean like do you commonly
eat like a croissant
so i i'm really good now because i think
about
i think one step ahead you know i'll
thank god i would really love to eat
this cookie
i'm thinking about okay well how am i
gonna feel after i eat this cookie
and i know that when i eat something
really sweet
i'll have like a bit of a crush and
it makes me crave more of it afterwards
like that's messed up my palate for the
rest of day if i have something sweet
i'm like
right well all i want now is sweet stuff
sugars like cocaine yeah you want more
and more
so i know if i stay away from sugar then
actually don't crave the sugar
so we haven't talked once there the
compliance or consistency with your
training
the hitting your protein getting it from
the right sources
getting enough sleep and hitting your
calories not once we talked about
pushable legs level of intensities
supersets reps weights
any of that stuff yeah and is that
that's purposeful
you're yeah i don't think that's
whether you're doing the drop set or
superset or anything like that means
you're getting more technical but i
think that's
in terms of the hierarchy of importance
that's like at the bottom
okay and then moving into training what
do you rely on now so let's say that
your
normal life with an okay level of
availability
what are you what's a typical sort of
week of training look like for you
so what i try and do is i'll i'll design
a split for myself and i'll follow it
for a few weeks and then i'll change it
up
and obviously i might not stick to all
the time if i'm doing like
you know like workouts with other people
and stuff but i'll have like i look at
my physique about okay so for the next
month i'm going to focus on
like maybe my hamstrings i'll focus more
on my shoulders there's like two or
three muscle groups of which are the
focus
i try and hit them more frequently so
overall the volume is higher compared to
other muscle groups
then i'll change that up uh you know the
next month
uh but the most important thing which i
try and do is
obviously to grow muscle is to overload
that muscle and when it gets to a point
where i actually can't lift anymore
then that's when i incorporate the
other forms of manipulating intensity
such as partial reps drop sets
supersets things like that you spoke
about form and
intensity in workouts how do you make
sure that you've constantly got that
happening
so this is a this is a funny one like if
i go into the gym
and i train alone and listen to my music
i am in the zone
like i like that is the one point in my
day where i'm like
really in my element i couldn't be
happier like i'm very passionate about
music when i'm listening to my music i'm
in the gym what are you listening to
most of the time it's like uk rap or
grind
i don't know why it just like hard to
relax today
no yeah i will not be sat at home on my
computer
listening to that because i'm like shut
the [ __ ] up like that's too intense
enough
yeah um so whatever now listen to that
i'm like really happy
there's a lot of times especially out
here in dubai those people want to train
with me and i'm like yeah okay we'll
we'll train together
and depending like everyone is very
different i have some people who are
trained with
who uh have like a mad session with
them usually they're the people who are
stronger than me they're bigger than me
i like training with them because
they lift heavier and i'm like more
likely to want to keep up with them
and they'll help spot me and so on if
i'm training with someone who
lifts lighter than me or just loves to
chat
i don't like training with them i find
it really difficult to train people who
don't shut the hell up like the talk all
the time because the session needs to be
intense i've been in the gym for an hour
so i need to make a count
and if someone's trying to like have a
proper catch up with me in between sets
you just talking to you know how to do
that yeah and if you have the energy to
have a full-on conversation after a set
then i really questioned how intense
that set was
so in terms of intensity if you're
working in a rep range of like eight to
but you're binning yourself on that you
must be overloading quite a lot yeah
it's very taxing on the body what
i will usually try and do is maybe like
the first or second surf like yeah i'm
pushing myself it's not quite a failure
and the last set that's the one where
it's like all out complete failure
the assistance of the spot taking me
beyond concentric failure and i'm like
literally moving to the point where i
can't even lower the weight like it's
that
intense um and usually yeah i'll come
out the gym i'll be pretty
drained um and that's
especially at my level of training that
is what is required for me to maintain
or to even grow further do you think is
that
the most common error that you see
people making when it comes to training
a lack of intensity a lack of overload
yeah i think people try to lift there'll
be a lot of people who will try and lift
as heavy as possible but the form is
crap
so it's like okay you're trying to like
let's say for example gray chest
all the tension is on your shoulder and
tricep so you're not really going to be
doing it a whole lot for your chest you
probably injure yourself at the same
time
but i think a lot of people they either
struggle to push themselves
to take themselves beyond that point
of you know discomfort and pain and go
into that
new horrible world and just stay there
for a bit particularly when it comes to
leg training
um and then a lot of people just
they just chat too much in the gym too
long an hour and a half two hours
which is there's no need to be there for
that long
who is the most intense training partner
that you've trained with
god that was a good question
[Music]
there's one i did recently this guy
called blessing the boogeyman
i forgot to say oh yeah yeah so he's
like his form is
pretty atrocious but in terms of
intensity he's pretty
like damn crazy um
god and then i did a session once with
dorian yates that was good fun
like when he's like coach i didn't train
with him he was coaching me
but when he's there coaching you just
like well i don't want to like a [ __ ]
in front of 28 so i'm
i'm going to push myself i really want
to have a leg day with tom platts
like i watch him train and i've seen how
he pushes other people i think that
would just be
i would certainly take myself to a
completely
different level of intensity that i've
ever experienced before and i like that
the thought of it actually scares me
but i would i would come out of it
thinking god that was so good
so tom platt is on the wish list who
else you want to train
uh callum von moga i think he's a cool
guy i'd like to do a collab with him
um simeon panda i've tracked him before
um we just not been in the same place at
the same time
uh and then in terms of celebrities like
a few people ask me like who is the one
celebrity you'd love to train with i'd
love to trade with the rock
i think that would be pretty cool that'd
be a big session yeah
um but yeah
i've had i've had some i've had some
pretty brutal training sessions in my
time
a lot of the the really intense ones are
just being like
not influencers just your typical
hardcore bodybuilder that doesn't give a
damn about social media or instagram
someone likes proper rough people from
newcastle geordies
no no no no just like not even i've had
some good sessions with him but like
just these problems when you're finding
gold stuff they used to go to men at
work
like just like for everyone who doesn't
know what men at work is
it's 50 of the people that train in
there the guys are training there are
still in their rigor boots
and their high vis from work they were
the same outfit every single session all
the benches are covered in
um like dust from graft and they've
still got their boots on
yeah it's like they'll just like
completely take the piss out of me
because obviously i'm there like my
nice outfit yeah looking like a pretty
boy in the bike yeah
and they took they took me through some
horrible sessions like i actually
remember like
doing legs and just feeling sick like
looking in the mirror covered in sweats
like pale as a ghost and like obviously
the form wasn't perfect or anything like
that but it was just pure
raw intensity like just keep going
keep going have you ever considered
training
in different sort of training styles
have you ever considered functional
fitness
crossfit any of that sort of stuff i've
tried it but honestly just
don't enjoy it i know you've done some
crossfit but
i think it's horrible like that style of
training like not
not one ounce of my body enjoys that
it's brutal
like proper brutal
i don't know why people do it i mean the
best thing about it is when the session
is finished and you're like
god that was really hard and i pushed
myself and it does turn you into a
conditioned
savage i will give it that but the
session itself when i'm doing it
that i i don't i don't like to do
anything endurance based
like once i've kind of hit the 15 rep
mark i'm like
[Laughter]
my heart then starts going boom boom
what about like a brazilian jiu jitsu
i'd be i'd be quite interested to do
that like either martial arts just
something about self-defense uh
yeah like learning a new skill i did
some work with brad
on the pads and i actually realized how
useless i was at like
throwing punches and combinations yeah
like just
how quick you have to be and the
position you have to get your body into
when you throw a punch
and protect yourself stuff i wouldn't
even think about
like uh you know when i was younger like
i got myself into a few scraps
but that's like that's not proper
fighting that's just like
swinging a monkey punch like yeah so
that's something which i definitely want
to do there's a few there's a few skills
which i
i would like to have under my belt i
need to stretch more
that is i was going to say in terms of
prehab rehab
protecting your body you don't do
anything no and that's like
the reason why i'm staying injury-free
is because i know
what my body can handle i don't do
stupid one-rep maxes
uh or like complex movements or
movements which i know my body is not
comfortable with doing
and the form is always slow and
controlled so in that sense i'm kind of
protecting myself because i won't be
doing this long-term future until i
can't basically i can't imagine my life
without lifting
but i would imagine if i do stretch you
know
the joint health would be improved
mobility much better i think
uh particularly with leg movements i
would be able to get a great range of
motion
um but it's just it's pure laziness as
to why i don't do it
must seem mad for some people listening
to look at your physique and
think that there's areas of your
training that you're lacking in yeah you
know that you've got laziness still in
there
yeah i think it's because i've not
needed because i know i can get away
with training without needing to do it i
just think well
i'm not going to do it path of least
resistance but it's one of those things
where i know if i did do it
and i was consistent with it
it would be highly beneficial but i
don't do it but not as beneficial as
maybe
another night out or another or a bit of
work yeah whatever yeah it's lower down
there
but you can i can make time i would
never say i don't have time
if it's something i really want to do i
will make time to do it like that
traveling a lot over the last few years
and obviously building up an audience
with 1.1 mil
subs on youtube now etc has that changed
your view on
relationships obviously you're
consistently in cities
with very transactional
relationships in them exotic women
exotic women
what has that changed your opinion on
relationships or your sort of viewpoint
what have you learned about
relationships
what i've learned is i'm not a point in
my life right now to be in a
relationship
i had the experience of being one
probably like
the first serious one i've had for a
while started this year
and she like literally was so sound
like she ticked all the boxes like wifey
material
but i just
i wasn't ready for that i think i hadn't
i had the experience of almost what life
would be like being sort of married
because of the whole uh lockdown
situation particularly here in dubai
um you pretty much weren't allowed to
leave the house
so we were in a relationship we we've
seen each other and then all of a sudden
it just got like really intense because
i was like well come
we might as well stay together because
she had a like a very small part
and she would have god if she had to
stay there
horrible for her so she moved in um
it was really like it was good but it
was like the most intense thing
i've done in terms of relationship i've
never lived with
a partner let alone
being with him 24 7 not being able to
leave the house
like for two months it was absolutely
ridiculous and uh
i was just like this this life isn't
for me and the weird thing was is like
because i was
i was with her for so long i didn't
apply
fantasizing about being with like other
women
it was weird like it was
there was that and then the fact that
when i went over to
ibiza i'd almost felt like i was
free again i could do what i want when i
left dubai
we said you know we'll we'll see how it
goes but i had no
no plans for it being very long-lasting
because i've been i've done a long
distance relationship before and it was
brutal like going extended periods of
times and not
sleeping with that person or anything
like that like i just didn't like it
and when i went to ibiza like it was
like starting from fresh
i wasn't in a relationship i could do
what i want to speak to whoever i wanted
to
and then i was like sleeping with a few
girls
and i was like the happiest i could
possibly be when i left it by i wasn't
really
that happy what was it about that was it
i think it was a combination of
everything like it definitely was not
her
it was a combination of um
just posts locked
was a weird place it wasn't the fun
dubai which i'm used to
a lot of my friends who i'm very close
with
who would have been in and out of the
city weren't because they weren't
letting tourists in
so i just missed socializing and meeting
new people
and with the lifestyle which i live at
the moment you know i'm
uh i'm traveling all over the place or
doing cool things every day or
you know in situations where there's
lots of girls around me if i'm like a
boat party
or doing something else or talking about
relationships
uh i wouldn't be able to be my true
self because i would always be thinking
right i need to be respectful to my
girlfriend
so i have to behave in a certain way or
i shouldn't be in the situation in the
first place shouldn't be with chris gale
yeah like being at like a pool party or
being on a boat
in my opinion that would be
disrespectful to my partner
if i was in a relationship and i don't
want to make someone unhappy
i think for in that situation she
deserved better
than me because i was not giving her the
proper
boyfriend partner experience which she
deserved because that's what she wanted
she was
she didn't like going out she's like
partying drink or anything like that she
just wants
a man to be loyal true respectful
and treated the way she deserves to be
treated and
i think it came to a point where i was
like i'm i'm not the person to provide
that
for her what would you change about
british culture
if you could like we've still got a lot
of buddies who are back in the uk
you've moved around being newcastle
spent a fair bit of time there not only
being a student but starting a business
then move to london then still will be
in touch with a lot of friends and
family
are there any elements of yourself that
you've changed over the last few years
that you wish
you could red pill those people on back
home as well
[Music]
i don't know because like because i'm
not in the uk like i don't mind just
like they can
do what they want uk doesn't affect me
but i think a lot of people from the uk
they just party way too hard like they
love to
just get on the drink the problem i had
when i lived in newcastle i had the best
group of friends
ever like i had such a laugh with them
we all had each other's back
it was a hell of a lot of fun but they
just partied too hard
like the alcohol the drugs and me being
in that circle
it was not good for where i wanted to
be in my life like that would just
pull me away from my goals in so many
different ways and what i noticed is i
had all these ambitions and goals for my
life and they didn't share those same
ambitions they're the type of people
that are probably going to be in
newcastle for the rest of their life
and will probably be doing the same
thing you know
for the next few years five years ten
years like that they're not going to
massively grow or evolve
but they're cool with that like they're
content that's their life but that's not
what i wanted for myself so one of the
hardest things i had to do was to just
to leave them all in pursuit of me
going to chase my own goals it's a
difficult decision yeah like i remember
when i left
newcastle it was like i hate it because
i
after being there for like eight years i
had so many friends there
moving to london didn't know anyone in
london like saying goodbye to my best
mate brad taran
like that was horrible i do i still miss
him to this day
like probably probably a good mate of
mine
but it was just something that needed to
be done
in order for me to you know moving to
london was the best thing i could have
done
because there was less of the party
scene less of a temptation
i was for the first time living by
myself there was no distractions
so i could just the productivity went
massively
and uh from then on that you know within
that first year of me starting youtube
i've got like 300 000 subscribers in the
first year and that was just from
grasping my ass off didn't really do
much on the weekend just kind of stayed
in
but i think after experiencing what that
was like you know just staying in not
really doing much
editing all the time was like god there
needs to be more to life than this
and i think that's what kind of pushed
me to want to travel
so you've tried you've straddled both
sides of the extreme though
you've gone from like my party to the
monastic there was there was the the
period in newcastle where it was like
fun it was crazy
um and then i decided i need to get away
from that move to london
and it was the complete opposite there
wasn't that balance
i was way too heavily involved with work
and not satisfying that other side of
life you know the enjoyment pleasure
experiences and things like that
um and that's when i decided okay yeah i
need to
not necessarily work less but just
switch a few things around that's the
hardest thing personally is someone who
wants to build a platform who wants to
do things that i care about and achieve
things that i'm proud of
but also wants to live and enjoy life
yeah that's not
by far that's the hardest thing i
experienced as well because you
if you're an ambitious person you have
all these goals for yourself and you
know what you need to do in order to
achieve those goals
but some of the the best
times of my life and the things i look
back on i just either laugh at or just
think oh my god that was so good or so
funny
they're the times when i was like either
out partying or just doing
fun things with my friends or maybe like
with a partner
basically something which is not work
related
despite the fact that you enjoy work
yeah
and i just remember just a few times
which are work related i think damn that
was like a really good day whether it be
a club or something like that but the
best and funniest times
have been not work related
and you know if like say for example
there's a holiday or there's an event
coming up or like
something which may involve alcohol
partying
one side of me is like i should avoid
that because it's not
going to help me achieve my goals doing
this that or whatever
maybe i'll be hungover the next day but
then other side of me like this is going
to be
absolutely hilarious and you and your
friends are going to be talking about
this the rest of your life
so i was like let's just do it i think
it's the 8 20 rule if 80
of the time you are working you're
doing something to help you progress
towards your goals
you know 20 of the time you're having
fun
doing whatever moment so be it so that's
the rule
that you rely on you try and aim for
like an 80 20 split
yeah but sometimes it swings one way and
sometimes 50 50.
what other lessons do you wish that you
could tell yourself 10 years ago
um it's funny because i've been asked a
few times and i think
where i am right now at 30 i'm so happy
with my life
that i wouldn't really go back and
change much because
what has happened in my life is not
being to this point today what i would
probably say is
uh i'll just say look social media is
going to be
huge get on that straight away
i think when instagram became popular
i didn't take advantage of that as much
as i could have i got on twit relatively
early compared to a lot of other
influences
i just thought it was a bit fun so i was
just like
you know just post basic pictures and
when really i should have dedicated a
lot more time each day
to create content for that platform to
help me grow
uh the same thing with youtube i
procrastinate for about a year before i
started youtube
because of my just fear of being on
camera which is like absolutely useless
and being on camera
if i'd started that earlier i feel like
i could have been
a little bit further ahead than where i
am now
uh and i think this is one thing which i
spent
years training my clients probably three
years training clients day in day out
i wasn't earning a huge amount of money
like in newcastle it's not the most
affluent area i'd probably make a 30
pound an hour training
client and i'd bust my balls all day
every day because i whenever i trade a
client i'd like to give them 100
of my time and effort when you do that
with five or six people at the end of
that you're just
wiped out and doing something like that
you can't scale
there's only there's a cap on how much
money you can make it's very time
intensive
and it took me far too long to realize
that this
this isn't the way forward the moment i
made that transition from training
clients to
bringing out a cheaper
service like a training program whether
it be an ebook or an
app based training program you can sell
an
unlimited amount passive income you make
money you sleep your job is just to
market it
that was the biggest game changer for me
that's when my income went like that
but i was like why the hell did i not do
this sooner
but i think all those thousands of hours
which i put into training clients
that made me a better coach like that
would
made me better uh talking about things
on youtube
and breaking things down there's a lot
of people now on social media
or who are proclaimed you know online
coaches
they've never trained clients in their
life like how can you be an online coach
you've never trained someone in person
or you don't have that experience
under the belt and i see it a lot now
there's a lot of people out there who
you know they have hundreds of thousands
of followers or like millions
they're offering like customized
programs
and it's like you are not you are not
doing these programs you are paying
somebody else
to put the programs together you may you
might not have even
built the programs yourself and i just
think like
how can you how can you do that how can
you be selling people a program which
you say you've made but you haven't
actually made you just paid somebody
else to do it
that's why i always pride myself on the
stuff i do like any program which i've
sold or any
plan i give to someone i've sat there
and i've like put it together myself
and there's a lot of people out there
who they are
in a position they are because of either
the way they look or just very
successful marketing
and the problem is there's so many
people this
is gullible or naive it's hard to tell
the difference yeah
they just fall into the trap somebody
who is very convincing
as a good salesman saleswoman and has
good marketing
you know that they're gonna get that
customer they'll get that client there's
a lot of coaches out there who really
know that stuff
uh you just don't have the following or
they don't get the income they deserve
because you know they're not either
taking a shortcut or they're just not
really decorating marketing themselves
what's the what's the main advice that
you give to a fledgling
content creator who wants to start
making money online or start vlogging or
youtubing or
instagram what are the things that you
would say that they need to get locked
down
i'll say first of all understand what
you're getting yourself into
like to to create content
good content it takes time and thought
particularly
like youtube i don't think a lot of
people understand the amount of effort
that goes into putting videos together
i know so many people are like yeah i'm
starting youtube channel they put out a
few
videos and they're like i'm not doing
that well you told me before we started
that you your most recent vlog had taken
three full days
of work to just film then you're edit
time
yeah well the edit time was kind of
within that as well
and i just thought like god that took
like quite a lot of time and even i was
questioning like is that
was that really worth it if a video gets
over 150 000 views or 200 thousand views
then i might okay
yeah that's good it gets more than half
a million i'm like okay it's very good
it goes like more than a million then
that's like yeah that's a really solid
video okay so we've got the you need to
know what you're getting so you need to
know where you're going
you need to at this stage you have to
figure out a way to stand out
like now it's like the most saturated
market ever
you have to ask yourself how are you
going to be different
you can't just try and copy someone else
uh
what do you think makes you different i
think one thing i wanna i think that's
helped me
to become is obviously the way i look
having a good physique can help
but that is not uh the only thing that's
important
you could be the type of person that
provides very informative information
like if you just provide good
information and it makes sense
then people will like that even if you
don't have a great physique people will
be like
yeah i'm learning a lot by watching this
guy's videos or content
you could have a great personality be
very charismatic
be very entertaining uh
you know if you are what is something
about you which is very engaging people
just want to watch
more than you are you'll be successful
i think with me uh
like i said there's been my physique but
i think i stayed very
true to who i am and i'm honest
and i like i just say it how it is
i've never tried to be someone i'm not
like what you see in the video
is me like i i honestly just feel like
i'm
a normal person i don't try and be like
super funny i don't try and be like
you know i don't try and talk about
things i don't understand if i don't
understand i either say oh yeah i don't
really know i just don't talk about it i
talk about things which i myself
understand and then
uh just share from experience
i think it one thing which kind of
helped me grow or like
the the say the love that's the wrong
word but the
people felt more of a connection was
when i opened up a little bit more
so when i talk about like my life my
problems
mistakes i've made just sharing my
thoughts
i think that can be quite good as well
it's very rare
to find online the vast majority of
content creators that i see
are fitting a mold that they think other
people want to see
and for the most part that involves a
bit of a
like a meta game where they're
projecting this version of themselves
this is
podcast chris this is vlog mike yeah and
totally correct some of the most engaged
bits of content i've ever seen on the
internet when people
genuinely open up about this the
vulnerability
about their concerns about their hopes
their dreams you know all this sort of
stuff
and that's certainly one way that you
can stand out you said you need to find
a way to stand up that's a fairly easy
way to stand out to just aim for honesty
yeah the things everybody is different
and each person is unique in their own
way
i i can't try and be somebody else like
i am mike thurston there's only one my
first and so just be
my person and
yeah like i said i think especially now
i just
i don't care anymore like the older i
get i just don't care about anything so
i'm more than willing to just talk about
things i've done in the past which
you are concerned if one of the videos
if you were to release 10 videos in a
row and all of them hit less than 150k
though yeah how would that make you feel
yeah that's a weird one
that would i would be disappointed
but i think what i would have to
think to myself right i see this all the
time now people blame the algorithm
it's like it's not the algorithm like
people are just bored
of the content you're putting out so i
would re-evaluate okay so
what is it that i'm doing because
something which i'm saying or doing the
video people are
starting to tune out it's either it's
just not valuable content or it's
getting a bit repetitive always getting
boring
so i need to switch up and i think this
is something which i kind of did
especially recently i used to do very
specific videos on training and
nutrition
in not much personality just me being a
coach
some of the videos did well but as a lot
of other people start to go into youtube
everyone's making these videos about
meal prep uh
food challenges or like how to building
chest full workouts things like that i'm
like
god i'm going to put up another workout
video like people are just going to get
bored with this so that's when i kind of
transitioned a bit more into vlogging
and lifestyle
because your life is
your life is no one else's life and if
you're giving people an insight to your
life
and i think realistically my life is
sometimes i think why the hell are
people watching me but
i'm in dubai doing quite a lot of mad
stuff basically i'm like oh
maybe this is quite interesting so i'll
just document it there's certainly one
part of youtube
that i feel quite uncomfortable about
coming from a podcasting background
my goal with recording a show is to try
and give the people that listen
a unique insight that helps them to
understand themselves or the world
around them
even if someone listens who has no
dreams of becoming a bodybuilding
youtubing
traveling person but they go actually
that's really interesting what mike said
about how he had to have faith that his
goals long term or what he wanted to do
and he needed to sacrifice something in
the short term like that or even if
they're just entertained
but my goal is not to look at an episode
you've done
uh if you've even been on a podcast
before yeah a long time ago
to look at that podcast and go right
that podcast did well
i'm gonna try and recreate that podcast
but you see these trends
like covid19 working their way
through youtube world oh so if we do how
much did i earn from this video video
yeah everyone's everybody starts to do
it or can we do a special forces
selection video and then that trickles
down or can we do a
like a go and see uh niall what's his
face the guy that does gymnastics and
then he'll go and do it yeah and he's
like
i i don't get me wrong it's a good idea
and the user views and clicks or clicks
but for me as a content creator waking
up on a morning
and looking at what someone else had
done and thinking
okay that's what i'm going to aim to do
it's like a being
all show and no growth yeah that's why
sometimes i try
not to watch other people's
youtube videos because i don't want to
get influenced by what they're doing
i'm intrigued as to why something will
also
blow up yeah sometimes it's the
thumbnail it's the title
it's the algorithm like youtube will
i think depending upon maybe the watch
time whatever it might be they just
decide to recommend a video to
complete strangers and for whatever
reason that video just gets lots of
views
you can't predict that that will happen
a lot of times
it's very sort of hit and miss but
you're right like
you shouldn't structure your content
based on what other people are doing i
think you have to just sit down and
just try and think of unique things to
do yourself it makes me really
uncomfortable though yeah
i i would love to just get
endless or like a hundred titles for
youtube
like the craziest like titles that would
make you think god
that would be a good video yeah because
if i have the title
i can go off and make the video the
hardest thing is to think of
the title so is that how you do your
video you begin with the title
and i try and work back from that i used
to sometimes i will do
because if it's a banging title i'm just
like what's a banging title that you've
done recently
uh how to walk yourself to 10 body fat
okay i like that like over half a
million views focused on i'm gonna guess
like neat
and yeah so it's basically how if you
can increase your daily step count
and do it consistently whilst doing
other things you can
reduce your body fat but the title is
that's like an interesting title it's
specific
because walking ten percent body fat
it's like oh
those two yeah sound like a
juxtaposition yeah so you've got that
and then you
speak to your video guy put a little bit
of stuff together
so it's the title and then i have like
the bullet points of how i'm gonna
do it sometimes if it's like the vlogs
i'll
pick the title based on the most
interesting thing that happened in that
video
but sometimes it's hard like i'll have
like it's an interesting vlog and cool
things have happened in it
but you have to think of a title and
it's like i hate being clickbaity
i don't like you know having a title
which is really
to do with the video or maybe has like
10 seconds
relevance to the video itself and at the
end of the day if you do have a
relatively boring title people are gonna
be like
no so it's always a fight between being
page three or being so subtle that no
one clicks on it yeah
and it's i don't want to be the type of
person
that makes videos to get attention
to do like dramatic things uh in order
to get the views in
i'd rather people be like yeah i'm gonna
watch that video because it might puts
out
good content and i won't have to
fall into that need of doing those
dramatic click-baity
titles you got fairly far without having
to rely on
yeah louis and and being in a ferrari
and stuff like that how much of a
difference because obviously people are
gonna go it's easy for him
he's got a videographer he's able to
rent or like borrow a car or a jet ski
or do the sort of stuff
like how much of that is making a
difference now is it only once you get
to a particular level
i think it just it makes it easier the
hardest thing i found was uh
like getting some of the shots and i
didn't like all the time just having to
talk to the camera
with that thing yeah so it's nice when
he's there and he can just capture
things naturally that's what i like the
most just capture capturing my day
naturally i hate it when things are
staged
when you know if you if you meet someone
you haven't seen for a long time
the most natural meeting is the first
meeting we're like oh my god i'm seeing
pages
imagine if you didn't get on video and
you're like oh we actually need to film
this again for
the video and it's just like i like i
hate doing
an intro to a video and then the other
person has to do the intro again
and it's like it's almost like you're on
a set and everything is just staged i'm
like
this isn't real anymore like i i want
things to be as pure as real
as they possibly can be so the good
thing about louis is
he can be there in the background and
he's filming and i can do
my stuff but i think some of the most
viable content which i put out
and when i uh open up is when nobody's
around and it's just me in the camera
because there's no distractions and you
know if i mess up then i can just start
again
sometimes if i'm trying to speak to the
camera
there's so many distractions around i'm
not concentrating still get you nervous
on camera whatever is 200 300 videos in
now
[Music]
uh i think the hard the thing i hate the
most is doing an introduction to a video
i don't know i don't know why it's like
just like so hey guys and
then and then this is like like that's
one thing i don't like
and i think yeah if i would probably get
a little bit nervous if i'm doing a
collab with someone huge
or someone i've like really looked up to
who would that be who would you get most
nervous doing an intro to a video in
front of
i don't know there was a few people who
are this is this is the weirdest thing i
find right
so if you're doing a collab with someone
you've never met before it's weird
because you've never met each other and
you're trying to act like
you are like friends and like the
chemistry is really good
and it's very if you've met each other
three seconds ago and it's like
you don't even know this person so
that's why sometimes
it's good to do a collab with someone
who you've already you've met them a few
times and it's like more natural
or doing a collab with someone who is
like very
sort of charismatic and has like a big
personality
because they kind of kill the tension
yeah yeah you just vibe off each other
yeah so who would anyone that you think
like that would that would make me
really nervous to be in front of them
[Music]
if you sat me down with rogan i'd
probably poop my pants
like just here oh yeah yeah three yeah
you know yeah if i went on the joe rogan
experience
i'll just be like oh my god there's
millions of people listening to me
and the first five minutes would be so
cringy probably i've spoken to i've got
a bunch of buddies who've been on the
show
or just friends that i've met through
doing this who've been on rogan a number
of times and they said the first time
if you could see under the table their
legs just going boom
even bouncing your leg up and down
desperately trying to get rid of this
anxiety
yeah incredibly sweaty hands desperately
trying not to touch anything
and then obviously like the route one
solution if you're on rogan is to just
have a spliff or a beer we don't want to
do that either because what if you [ __ ]
up and say the whole thing
um yeah it's that's a level of of
pressure that i think i don't know i
think it's it's it's also quite tough as
well
i remember there was this one time i had
to do an interview with lewis hamilton
this is when i did it like mad collab
with puma
where they got me involved and they just
wanted they wanted me to do
like a short interview with lewis
hamilton and
it was annoying because i didn't really
get to ask the questions which i wanted
to ask they just gave me some questions
which i had to ask
and anyway we got there he obviously
came up shook his hand had a little bit
of a chat
and then we sat down and i kid you not
there's about 30 people
just staring at me cameras everything
silence and i was just like
like this god bro my second ever episode
for this show
is with dave castro the director of the
crossfit games this is a guy that i've
looked up to on being a fan of crossfit
for like 10 years
and it's for reebok brand new shoe that
they're releasing exactly the same thing
so the mark we just finished a workout i
binged myself and heart rate's like 180.
now like right chris we've got about six
minutes and then dave's going to be over
there ready to go and i'm thinking right
i need to get my heart rate i somehow
need to get it down but it doesn't want
to go down now
whether i'm recovering or not and yeah
sat down in front of this big group of
people
and they asked about what's your
favorite reebok shoe and he just
basically said i don't really care about
them
and i saw the marketing director from
reebok go like this
that's behind the thing i'm trying to
balance all this stuff so yeah i imagine
lewis hamilton's another
another another level of that yeah i
think
it depends on the the person as well
like if they're if they're quite a
serious
intense person i would be more
nervous and just be like i need to be
difficult to break the ice but if it's
somebody who's just like proper easy
going and they've got a good chat
i think it's definitely a lot easier i
don't know
yeah we got we're gone on that one so
we're just on one angle now
uh two questions left um
the first one is what's your prediction
for
the next five years
platform-wise content-wise what are you
thinking is going to continue to be
attempted to do a tick tock are you
thinking youtube's going to continue to
grow
i think youtube will still be around for
the next few years the thing is annoying
me is the whole censorship
thing i think it's getting a little bit
like too strict with what you kind of
can't say
like the free speech i think is going a
little
out the window like now if you're
talking about sensitive subjects or
conspiracy theories youtube would just
take your video down to it like
well that's a bit harsh have you been
pot for any of that stuff yet no because
there's things i want to talk about i'm
like
just don't say it like it's best not to
say it sometimes particularly for
something which is quite a touchy
subject
because you are going to have people who
will agree or disagree and it's mad how
people will just not like you because
you have different opinions because you
picked an opinion yeah basically it's
mad that's why i absolutely
stay clear that um
instagram i imagine would be around for
a while tick tock i've not
i don't really know much about tiktok
i've thought about potentially getting
onto it but i just thought the problem
is now can you see you doing a dance
i yeah a bad one um i
i would much rather be on top of my game
and focus on
like two platforms rather than trying to
do
five and just overwhelm myself and not
put out the best content
so youtube is always gonna be my focus
instagram obviously
my folks as well i should place with
more folks on instagram if i want to
grow
but i was possibly thinking about
podcasting it's been
toying with my mind over the past few
years because
uh the thing with my youtube videos is
most people will tune into youtube video
average view length six
minutes eight minutes and what do you
want to hit like 10 to 15. yeah 10 15. i
don't think
so you're looking at like a 33 yeah like
attrition right
okay yeah uh but there's like it's
annoying because when i've cut videos
i'm like all this information is useful
but people will
tune out what's not visually pleasing
this isn't the right platform for this
content
and the best content the best platform
for that to be on would be a podcast
and what i get a lot of satisfaction out
of is having conversations like this
with other people who are on the same
level they got same you know ambitions
but they are an expert in their own
field because i know not only will i
benefit from the conversation because i
learn
but the audience benefits as well
because they learn
and i think that would provide me with a
hell of a lot of
satisfaction but the thing is if
if i'm going to do it i have to go all
in i have to
fully commit to it i don't like doing
things half-assed
and particularly with the way my
lifestyle has been over the past
two years i think trying to do a podcast
would have been
overwhelming uh in terms of the workload
maybe the youtube would have
suffered or certainly would have had a
lot less free time and i like to have my
free time
but i think in terms of
me going to that next step you know i'm
30 years old now
i feel like i've gained a lot of
experience i certainly have a lot more
to talk about than i did when i was 25 i
think i first told you the idea when i
was 26
but what i could talk about now compared
to when i was 26 to be held a lot more
i've got more influence now in terms of
the people i could reach out to
and i think in terms of
just keeping my
you know my brand and me in the game as
being a person of influence and
importance
having a solid podcast would be hugely
beneficial and i don't necessarily
because you know what i said with the
youtube videos
you know i could spend like a lot of
time going out there trying to get the
visuals
maybe it's like a for a 30-second edit
i'm like god
like that was a lot of effort i'm happy
with the results but there's a lot of
effort
and it hasn't actually necessarily
developed you as a person i like it and
it's just like doing the same thing over
and over again just to get that shot
whereas a podcast you don't need the mad
visuals or anything like that it's just
like two people sat in a room having a
conversation
i wouldn't do personally any of the
editing on filming i'd hire someone set
everything up
uh switch the angles and then i can have
that conversation with
someone and then that's that they go i
think you do well man
i'd tune in i'd subscribe yeah you got
one subscriber at least
and i obviously i think the the most
challenging thing which i'm sure you
have
figured out is just becoming a good
conversationalist and asking the right
questions keeping a conversation flowing
and i would imagine one of the hardest
things is just reaching out to people
first you've got to email them message
them have that conversation and then try
and find
a place where you can both be at the
same time and then scheduling time i
know there's a few times you've messed
with me and i've
just been being proper flaky and just
it's ongoing for three years yeah
so like i'm sorry for that there's
obviously a lot of time and effort which
has just been
wasted because i've not but when you are
jet setting around the world yeah it's
just trying to grab and grab a little
but no i think that you are right
there's certainly i wonder how many
youtubers would increase their stock
by adding a podcast onto the arm of
their youtube channel
and i wonder how many youtubers would
get totally rumbled yeah either having
nothing to say yeah outside of a script
yeah
because i think there's a lot there's a
lot of people who don't go onto youtube
from instagram they're big on instagram
because they look good and their content
is good
but they don't have a huge amount to say
or they're actually not that intelligent
there's a lot of youtubers who maybe
they have more to say
or they're good at the visual side of
things but they can't carry a
conversation
so yeah i think definitely there'll be
fewer people
in the youtube space who would be able
to maybe do that long form and i don't
know if i would be successful or not
i think if i put my mind to something
i will figure out a way to make it work
that's like the mentality i've had
throughout my entire life so if i was to
do this
then i would have to go all in and i
would put in the effort to go and
just learn to be a better
conversationalist and how to actually
conduct a proper
like podcast um
because i know for a fact the first few
ones would be [ __ ]
yeah just weird no podcast has done a
good first episode yeah ever
uh last question um what are your goals
over the next year have you got anything
that you're working toward at the moment
is there anything that you want to try
and develop
so there's always with me i always like
to see growth in all the areas
of which i'm sort of working on so
it's nice to see the youtube views
subscribers go up
same like instagram things like that in
terms of revenue like yeah i want to be
making more money who the hell doesn't
want to be making more money
i have a new app which is coming out
in december so i've got a company called
genflow they've
basically put it together and that's
going to be a subscription-based app
which is something which i'm really
happy about because for the first time
ever i can
offer people like a a platform where
they can choose how many days per week
they want to train they can always
choose their split
and it will be the most sort of
user-friendly
uh almost like i'm there to help conduct
their session
so there's that which when it comes out
there'll be a lot of work which goes
into marketing that's gonna be called
i don't know yet cool i was going to
call it first but i don't think that's
first is the clothing line i don't think
that's got a ring to it with the app
itself there's the clothing brand which
has been up running for the past
year that's been mostly swimwear focus
but now it's going to branch out into
gym where
so i have a new launch for that in
november and then we have like
track suits um
[Music]
accessories more things coming out in i
think it's february
but the sky is the limit with that one
like that has the potential
to be huge but in order for that
to grow i need to build a team because i
i've got so many things going on at the
moment the way it's kind of been running
in the
the past year it's not had my full
attention
and i've tried to do a lot of stuff
myself
so i would need to i think my next step
is to
build a team to grow a team have them
handle all the things which i am either
not good at or just don't have the time
to do
and then me continue to do what i'm best
at doing but this is something which i
don't have a huge amount of experience
in
i've said this for the last year that if
someone
could create a course on how to find
train and integrate a va or pa yeah
i i'd happily pay two grand yeah like
overnight how do i
source someone who is great at
responding to emails dealing with guest
requests paying all of the
making sure that the advertisers have
paid their invoices on time i know that
rogan doesn't have a pa
but his life is so distributed he
doesn't also
handle his own like advertising yeah he
doesn't have to make sure that
young jamie sent the audio file off to
the video editor so it could get
uploaded onto spotify
so i think i i there's a lot that i like
about being a
an independent creator and being in
control i really enjoy
being the person that reaches out to my
guests that gets to message you and say
when can we
when can we do stuff but like chasing up
advertisers for
invoices and you know all that sort of
stuff have i paid
out the splits from youtube ad revenue
to the people that need paying
like that really could be done by
anybody yeah
and like like you said i like to be in
control and when i do something i do to
my best ability
i would be very tough to give that
responsibility
to somebody else you're limiting your
ability to scale that yeah
exactly so it's i'm like i said it's
just finding that
that one person or the first few members
of staff who are just your dream
members of staff who just do everything
like
and they're a pleasure to be around like
where the hell do you find them so it's
i was talking with stephen bartlett
guys ceo of social chain and stephen i
went for dinner with him and a bunch of
his
guys the other day and his new manager
is two weeks old
he's been with him two weeks not two
week year old um and
he stephen just put out a post on his
socials
saying i need a new manager
here's the email address yeah send me
what do you think i need to know so he
received
6 000 email emails right so he's going
through and i
george my buddy asked him so how did you
filter through 6 000 emails
says the first thing i did was just go
through them like next next next
and just do it based on formatting like
if it was formatted well
then it it got moved if it was formatted
badly it got deleted
and then filled it through for the three
fill through and sure enough this guy
now is flat he was in dubai the other
day because steve was out here in dubai
then steve's got this meeting with the
ceo of huell because he's going in-house
with huel to do all this sort of stuff
and this dude's just being dropped into
a bottomless pit of graft but he's there
and he's ready to do it yeah um
so yeah i think in fact like if i was to
put a story up
and just bullet point points of the
requirements of what i would need
and maybe be quite sort of strict with
it to eliminate
the riffraff yeah uh
maybe i would have less emails but i
know they'll be like people see my
lifestyle and be like
i want to work just be on that a part of
that okay
i get people message me saying look i'll
come and work for free
i just want you you don't want the guy
that's free though no yeah i really do
appreciate that when people reach out to
content creators and say that they want
to contribute
but the problem is price is an indicator
of quality
yeah the the person who will reach out
and say mate i will make your life a
hundred times easier but it's going to
cost you 40 grand a year yeah you're
like
oh okay now if that was a conversation
to be had that's why i never
i never ask for anything for free
because i know like if i was to go and
train someone
for free i wouldn't put in as much
effort because i know i'm not getting
paid for this so
you know like what's the point and
realistically you know if i ask a
cameraman or whatever like or can you
come and do this for free
they don't put in the same amount of
effort
so even if someone does like a favor or
anything like that i'm like look i'm
gonna pay you
for this don't worry and they're always
they'll put in that extra
effort which is what i want it'll be
interesting to see what happens over the
next year man i think
we're certainly going to see it feels to
me personally like instagram's kind of
hit its peak
i just can't see that facebook's already
on that route down twitter's had like an
interesting resurgence which has been
quite
maybe powered by people like donald
trump i suppose um
as a place to go for short little clips
of news
i certainly think long form is going to
do well tick tock i'm not convinced on
whether or not that's going to stay
around
uh maybe maybe not i certainly don't
think it's going to push into older age
brackets though
so we're like outside of the observable
universe of that like we're not getting
younger yeah that's not right for me now
i'm in i probably say i'm in my prime
now i don't know how many years i've got
left to kind of rely on my looks and my
physique that's not gonna last forever
so you know once i get past 35 hitting
40 yeah i want to still look good for me
but not going to look as good as you did
yeah that's when i need to maybe start
relying on
something else man thank you so much uh
people want to check out your stuff
where should they go
just youtube instagram search for mike
this and you'll find me if you want any
training programs like this and dot co
uk and best from shorts in the game
thirstaware.com
linked in the show notes below brother
thank you it's been a long time coming
[Music]
peace